have a look at the first question and I
hope you see these questions are clearly
related to one another right
why don't you is pair three and four is
a pair I suppose it in exam and in the
age of C you'll often see these as one a
part one part two
like you don't Roman numerals that's how
they often denote these questions are a
unity we're actually trying to hold your
hand through this and give you some
cleaners so the question is what does
one have to do with two any takers you
can give me an obvious answer if you
like this consensus what's the obvious
thing that is in common between one and
two yeah this guy here and this guy here
right coincidence I think not so the
question is how do you then I mean being
within is not a cure right how do you
use this to help you with this well I
want you to think back to a movie
inequalities and I keep pressing this
question whenever you see algebra
whenever you're manipulating symbols
think of a picture which is why that's
nice thing I should do is draw a picture
what this is asking is 1/2 X minus 1 I
can think of that as a straight line
right in fact I can just substitute it Y
is less than or equal to 1 you see that
comes from you now Y is about up and
down it's about up and down it's this
axis here which I gives me quick label
all right let me do ya the important
stuff now therefore if I read Y is less
than or equal to 1 what I'm asking is
okay very clean
where is this graph less than 1
vertically
ok now y equals 1 it's not on like that
so I put it there if that's negative 1 I
guess according to Scout that would be 1
so I'm looking for the parts of this
graph that are beneath one where one of
those parts of the graph the answer is
it's all this stuff right see all of
this stuff is beneath like was one do
you agree now we know vertically where
it is but the question of course here is
just do X's which is about left and
right yeah so therefore you have a look
at that value you got er and because you
guys have you know grid paper and that
kind of thing yours is accurate this
should line up with 4 yeah I mean you
can even kind of get to in your way
there by thinking for look the gradient
here means you go across 2 of 1 that
means you're across 2 of 1 right because
great is consistent across the straight
line naturally you don't have to appeal
to a big job to do that you can just do
this just peel it by algebra what were
you steps yeah so that would make this X
minus 2 is less than or equal to 2 and
then you can see it's just one line to
my
okay fantastic alternatively you could
add one to both sides
same operations different order okay and
you can verify yeah look see X is less
than or before it's that way do you
agree because that's the part that I
shaded now you know the one in two are
connected you know that three and four
and connected hopefully you can see that
the top pair and the bottom pair are
also connected you all probably have
graphic this this is the easy way y
equals x squared is out the nice simple
parabola it's just being taken from the
origin and mr. duck a you that's the
effect that it's plus one so I hope
you've got something like this okay now
let me back up a little bit see there's
a one there right in order to know
conclusively that this is the graph that
you're talking about through I chained
to add what's called a point for scale
need some coordinates on you and however
for this question for this graph I do
not need appointment for scale could
anyone suggest to me why is it that this
one need one and this one does not what
you reckon duckling using pens before
yeah fantastic so if you have a look at
this one right because I own and
hopefully put on two intercepts right
that graph has to be that there's
nothing else it could possibly be that
fits these information okay you've got
two intercepts BAM that's the other
straight line that passes through both
okay but this guy as I've drawn him
actually could be a whole bunch of
different parabolas
what else could be the equation that
parabola right now yeah just great yeah
very good I could pretty much put any
positive number out front he on the plus
one will still be there and it would
just change the scale of this dude right
it would be fatter or thinner and you
can't really tell the number because you
have there holes in this game so if you
draw a new order that looks exactly like
that I'm going to encourage you to put
on a point make it easy for self pick an
easy point like say one two you don't
have to pick hard numbers but you don't
have any x-intercepts to go from so
therefore you've got to lift yourself up
okay now I know conclusively that's that
okay last question and here's where you
probably looked at this and thought
really did we really have to draw that
the outer was so simple but down here if
the graph is gonna be super helpful
watch when you're doing you're working
right
almost certainly
that way almost certainly your first
line is that do your great do most
people do that well that's fine that's
okay imagery didn't okay where would you
go from here now do you remember we did
that lesson on equations inequalities
and we noticed well in most cases you
can treat any inequality identically to
an equation right like all of these
steps would have worked just fine if it
were an equal sign not only was calling
it and then you get to this and you're
like oh because if you take square roots
of both sides you end up with that what
do you put on the right-hand side
you've at least got to have that because
that's a square root but we've trained
ourselves from looking equations just
say this my mother's tree not a train
but then you think wait wait a second
what does that mean like you're greater
than this one and this one what is going
on we need to do this differently we
need to approach it differently and the
way we're gonna do it is by coming back
to unwrap write x squared plus 1 that's
what it's like x squared plus 1 is
greater than 4 what is this asking in
terms of this do you know how I did it
yeah so remember I can rewrite this if I
thought of that as wife whose whatever I
can rewrite this as Y is greater than 4
well Y's are about political values up
and down where is y equals 4 on my graph
there's one there's two do you have
enough space when your coordinate axes
if I go three and four like that just
like I did up here with what it was one
I can slot in y equals four
now what this is asking is when are you
vertically above four so which parts of
the prattler am i interested
yeah I just thought you firmly describe
it is it's like the bits above here on
the outside and the bits over here
they're also on the outside question of
douchey okay so at the moment like see
this question here solve this and graph
it on a number line
so what I'm trying to do right now is
get the first part of crunch soul I'm
trying to get out of this and the other
inequalities the set of solutions for
this okay I'll come to the shady
NewsView okay let's come back do you
remember if this were an equation you
take the square root of both sides right
and you would get this and when it's an
equation we were fine with the plus
minus right that's all good my question
to you is what is the significance of
this to this where r + 4 - 3 + 3 on this
diagram
well it does say X equals right so these
are horizontal values I'll show you
exactly where they are and you should
draw them when you're david x equals 4 3
is right there
do you agree I think about just put it
back into here right if X were rid 3
then Y would be 3 3 squared which is 3
plus 1 which is 4 all right so that's
why the coordinates there are 3 3
come on 4 so far so good and in the same
way whereas negative root 3 over on the
reflected side right so here that's
negative root 3 and again you can supply
it into the equation you look at why it
was for surf and this is why this is so
useful right graph it on a number line
you're looking for X values the ones
that work we want it on the outside over
here to the right you see that's how I
capture just part of the graph so I'm
going to go from root 3 and I'm going to
draw this way okay that is part of the
solution on the number line you train
now you in here go ahead plug in U and
this inequality will be true in the same
way over on the left hand side from here
after negative infinity those are also
part of the solution okay so how do you
stay back in algebra
if I say this party will get from left
to right that first puppet is X is less
than negative Ridge week yeah what about
this right in time X is greater than
positive root of 3 okay now remember I
talked to you a little bit before about
commas and words that go between things
what where it goes in here now I'm going
to suggest the most powerful word is all
the most dangerous word is and and comes
in it's important later on like huh I
use the word and because I don't care
how many numbers you know there reasons
a number that is simultaneously less
than negative 3
and also greater than 3 at the same time
so we can't use and in this case I'll
talk about here in a second I just want
you to point notice right now you can't
just go from here and then take the
square root of both sides it's not an
equation remember I'll try to emphasize
to you before word inequalities are
different things that's why if you've
got this and you take reciprocals it's
not just like oh I did the same thing to
both sides you're not doing the same
thing to both sides and when you
multiply by negative and so on
inequalities are different objects